[Musica]
sono 15 anni
se chiudo gli occhi io ricordo il
profumo a destra della foto il profumo
del risotto della mia mamma
il ricordo una bellezza di stare su kuyt
al tar della rossa che aveva fatto il
mio nome io non avevo un po vicino e mi
ha fatto una talea bellissima io mi
spingevo mi spingevo su questa altalena
perché volevo toccare con i piedini la
montagna volevo questo volevo vedere
oltre
vuole non capire cosa c'era oltre a
quella montagna questo costa questa
altalena di un paese della casa che
avevamo in pelle già tura io sono nata a
torino in un paesino un segno nelle
valli di lanzo avevano detto che su
quelle montagne dopo c'era la francia e
io devo curiose volevo capire
facciamo due cose avevo capito che se di
spingerlo dal suo poteva
verona potevo potevo andare spingere la
sempre più forte ma se quello dove
spingeva come quando arrivava il mio
padana ecco allora potevo potevo ancora
andare più forte
no e quindi c'era c'era questo questa
voglia di conquista di vedere le cose
che si trova tutto tutto possibile
passavo ore intere su quella terrena che
stavolta punto da sola mi piaceva e mi
piace tuttora stare da sola mi è
l'altalena è poi diventata anche un
libro ci ha fatto la storia perché certo
tutto mi è capitato è stato quasi un
omaggio terapeutiche che molte ragazze
che io conoscevo che conosco durante
convegni eventi come è come questo con
me commenta telex diceva no ma come hai
fatto a fare tutte queste cose e quindi
a un certo punto ho detto che mi scrivo
mi metto lì proposte vere e vediamo
quante cose ho fatto perché ho scoperto
che poi le donne fanno un sacco di cose
ma non li raccontano non ne raccontano
che cosa stabile non siamo abituati a
fare tante cose non raccontarle
e quando qualcuno ci dice se ibra ma tu
guardi ci trova non è vero e noi no
invece bisogna dirlo bisogna iscriversi
bisogna dirlo perché può diventare di
modello per
e altre le altre donne ma la tenace
anche accettare nuove sfide
allora in questa foto sotto col mio papà
il mio papà è stata una grande persona
ma non perché è diventato imprenditore
illuminato ma perché era sopravvissuto
un campo di concentramento
pensate un po e questo ho avuto ha avuto
il coraggio di insegnarmi il valore
delle briciole del pane eh sì perché le
briciole del palermo
quando sento il campo di concentramento
hanno un valore e quindi questo nuovo
invece di portarmi a torino il
bollettino lo portava in fabbrica invece
che portargli i giardini lui mi portava
in fabbrica e che mi è diventato
diventato normale vivere nella fabbrica
a sentire il profumo dell'acciaio
quindi era un habitat assolutamente
normale lui tuberi e andare in fabbrica
la domenica pervenire le postazioni di
lavoro se erano pulite se era tutto a
posto perché mi ha passato tutta la vita
il posto di lavoro certo chi fa per
scoprire come faccio io delle polizze
tener creare utili ma inutili poi vanno
però vanno oltre che investiti nella
ricerca e sviluppo
parla rimessi sul territorio perché il
territorio che ci ha dato tanto e
dobbiamo restituire dobbiamo
continuamente restituire io mi definisco
una donna di fabbrica e sapete cosa
pensate che tutte le volte io faccio mi
capita molto spesso di parlare in
pubblico perché cercava decina di anni
fa ho capito che dovevo restituire al
mio paese e dovremmo far capire la
fatica
dovevo far capire che la fatica di
lavorare in fabbrica è bello il sudore
citare fabbrica ha preso e quindi questo
è un messaggio molto forte ho aperto la
fabbrica lo aperte le scuole le offerte
agli studenti le offerte all'università
l'ho aperta e ci parlo aperta tutto
quello che potevamo mettere in
connessione perché la fabbrica non può
stare senza la cultura e la cultura non
può stare senza la fabbrica
allora che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
aperto pur se l'ho dentro la fabbrica il
museo delle chiavi perché pensate adesso
io lavoro in questa azienda che fa che
abidal 1770 siamo la più antica famiglia
al mondo che continua a fare lo stesso
mestiere e avevo usato delle chiaviche
in più è più ricco museo privato ma il
più ricco di oggetti di tutta europa e
ne fa la differenza perché capisci
sempre da dove sei nato è stato facile
lavorare nell'azienda dove lavoro adesso
che facciamo anche a me no perché io
avevo lavorato nell'azienda del mio papà
e mio nonno aveva cominciato a fare le
cucine a legna le cucine economiche
alenia per casa e poi per i ristoranti e
poi mio padre aveva ampliato al business
quindi da torino eravamo arrivati a
conegliano e di arrivare aveva iniziato
questo business delle cucine e bene
allora è evidente che quando tenta di
business è convinta che sia così per
tutta la vita
e invece no nel 96 è stata bene tutta
l'azienda
quindi dopo una bellissima esperienza di
aver lavorato col mio papà che deve
essere la figlia e la sorella questa
cosa si interrompe e poteva essere un
grande problema perché uno che è
abituato per un fan di business e sei
abituato ad avere
un'azienda questo infatti di trovare
lavora questa 30 ci sarà tua per sempre
non è così
non è così e che cosa è successo che una
mattina mi sono svegliata e ho detto ma
forse una grande opportunità forse devo
vedere una cosa che non avevo fisso
prima e sono ispirata e una delle prime
cose che ho fatto è stata che dopo un
viaggio in america aver visitato la
comunità amici sopra per questo questi
questi di questo modo di arredare le
case dove immobili devono essere utile
estetici che razionali e quindi capisco
che il country americano non c'entra
niente
sono e la cultura anni è stata portata
in america che gli americani che non
avevano storia se ne sono impossessati
di che cosa succede se dico beh allora
ricominciamo daccapo chiusa
nell'esperienza della mare ricominciamo
con lei con la casa di sei e che cosa
vedo vito delle pagine da via migliore
amica per saper fare della mia mamma
rivedo queste belle che fanno delle cose
meravigliose trasformano i trasformano
dei pezzi di stoffa in cose meravigliose
allora facciamo una connessione il suo
talento il mio talento e ne nasce una
storia fantastica fantastica e si è però
poi a un certo punto questa storia
fantastica deve finire perché nel
frattempo per tutta la terra
mio padre mio marito mi coinvolge in
questa sua attività nelle chiede e io e
con il suo a tenere tutto perché sono
madre di sei figli e quindi diventa
complicato gestire la famiglia e come si
gestisce una famiglia con sei figli si
diventa maratone di assortisti perché
l'unico modo per sopravvivere se non lo
fai non c'e la voglia fare quindi devi
diventare sportiva di cercare di tenere
in allenamento
la tenacia e la resilienza e quindi
eccomi nasce lì nasce il mondo
dell'hacking di come si può
come si può prima c'erano una fabbrica
sapete come si fa nei momenti di crisi
si assumono le donne e di che fa la
differenza non si lasciano a casa alle
donne
ricordatevi e lo dico io che ho sei
figli
chi meglio di sé
non è mica un problema la maternità chi
ve lo ha raccontato che sta raccontando
delle grandi bugie sono i talenti che
servono nelle aziende
quello mi ha bisogno perché il maternità
necessaria poi c'è un'altra cosa che
devo sempre ricordare che citrico che le
donne vanno pagate come gli uomini
perché se io guardo io ho sei figli
quattro maschi e due femmine le mie due
figlie femmine hanno fatto fatica a
studiare e posizionarsi sul mondo del
lavoro esattamente come sui loro
fratelli marsi per carità non certo di
meno perché io con la fatica che faccio
tutti i giorni dovrei meritare un
centesimo in meno di quanto noi ci
alterniamo la guida dell'azienda di tre
anni in tre anni di tra me e mio marito
perché dovrei prendere un centesimo meno
e tutto questo è tutto questo e valore
qui e cosa facciamo da azienda
metalmeccanica è sempre avuto una come
posso dire ha sempre avuto una gestione
al maschile passato da un capostipite
all'altro della famiglia bianchi sintra
nome di corpo e decidiamo dal 2002
adesso di alternarsi alla guida di tre
anni più tre quindi prima mio marito e
poi io e di passare a un 40 per cento di
donne in età fertile in età fertile
l'anno scorso abbiamo gestito se
maternità questo che cosa vuol dire che
bisogna adattarsi al cambiamento che
tutto quello che noi vediamo io potevo
vivere come come una tragedia guardo
potevo poteva essere una tragedia
aveva fatto un campo di particole campo
di concentramento poi aver poteva essere
una persona triste arrabbiata tutta la
vita era la persona più positiva di
questo mondo l'opportunità di tool
attrezzata chiusa l'azienda è stata per
tutta l'azienda e sono ripartita con
un'altra con un altro pensiero un altro
progetto ho chiuso la casa di zecca che
era un mio grandissimo progetto perché
non potevo più riuscire a lavorare solo
sui due progetti quindi grandi
cambiamenti grandi cambiamenti e la
nostra capacità di adattarsi al
cambiamento ecco perché io cito oltre
sempre la tenacia alla residenza da
resilenza che ti fa venire ti fa
arrivare alla fine delle maratone e poi
come come annunciato prima io sono
presidente dei cursori cinesi benessere
e che c'è tra una donna di fabbrica dei
musei civici
sapete perché centro perché mi occupo
riorganizza
e l'organizzazione le persone voi che
siete qui questa sera con me che siamo
un'organizzazione dietro le
organizzazioni ci sono le persone ma
dietro ogni persona che lavora pubblico
nel privato ci sono le loro emozioni e
quindi se noi andiamo a lavorare nelle
emozioni delle persone li facciamo al
cambiamento
quindi io ho trovato che nella mia vita
è importantissimo la contrattazione il
rispetto del talento altrui
e ricordatevi che se dove lavorate non
mi viene riconosciuto talento
io vi do un consiglio sono soprattutto i
giovani è cambiata la loro
sapete perché prima o poi si è
certamente e fece volta qualcuno b
qualcuno lo capisce che siete bravi vi
ferma e riporta in squadra perché questa
è la differenza
non dovete mai aver paura di cambiare
non perché forse la cosa più grande e io
ho visto mio perdere morire a 86 anni in
un minuto prima di morire aveva un libro
in mano la formazione continuare a
formarsi a studiare per cambiare
probabilmente se io non avessi tutto
questo questo questa voglia non sarei in
tutti questi mondi diversi che rimette
insieme
e insieme contaminano la mia vita in
modo tale che quando io tornai fabbriche
e un passato una giornata nella
fondazione tolto il valore aggiunto che
ho appreso della fondazione dentro la
fabbrica
ecco quindi il mio grandissimo augurio è
veramente di sprono ad avere il coraggio
di tirare fuori tale aiuto perché
abbiamo bisogno
grazie
[Applauso]